يبدون حكومه جورجيا ميلونيا اليمنيه نفذ
التعهداتها بتشديد القيود على قوارب
المهاجرين التي ترثوا على سواحل البلاد
بين ضفه هربوا منها وضفه اوروبا التي
يحلمون بها فقد منعت سلطات الايطاليه
اليوم مركبه سفينه انقاذ في سواحل صقليه
من دخول الاراضي الايطاليه وسمحت فقط
بنزول القاصرين والمرضى وطلب وزير
الداخليه الايطالي سفينه الانقاذ بمغادره
المياه الاقليميه الايطاليه وعلامتها
العشرات ممن لم يسمح لهم بالنزول هذه في
وقت نشد فيه ثلاث صفوف انقاذ اخرى تقل نحو
التسع مئه مهاجر راسيه في عرض البحر ناشدت
بالسماح لها بان ترثوا في ميناء امن لكن
لم يستجب لطلبه
احتجت منظمات انسانيه وحقوقيه على اليتي
الاختيار تلك باعتبارها غير قانونيه وغير
انساني عضو البرلمان الايطاليه المنتمي
للمعارضه ابو بكر الصماهورو والذي كان
حاضرا لدى نزول المهاجرين ندد بما وصفه
التمييز والاختيار بين مهاجرين غرقت
فازوارقهم وقطعوا رحله المحذوفه بالمخاطر
للوصول الى اوروبا وقالت في تغريده على
تويتر سيتم الطعام بهذا القرار لدى الهيئه
المختصه اذا تم رفضه الناجين المتبقين
[موسيقى]